Every couple of years,
mega-sporting events, like the
World Cup and the Olympics,
give us a glimpse
into the outer bounds
of human performance.
Surrounding that spectacle quite literally
is an entirely different calculus,
the decision to even put on
the games in the first place,
Once a highly sought role,
hosting a mega-event is now
an entirely different proposition.
One that politicians, governments,
executives, and citizens are asking,
"Is it worth it?"
What is the change in tourism
during the games and after the games,
controlling for other variables?
What is the change in fiscal revenues?
What is the change in employment?
What is the change in GDP, and so on?
We don't see these gains materializing.
There's some big numbers that go around
for Qatar's spending on this tournament.
I'm worried that the
government will be surprised
at how many people leave
after the event is all over.
I can see why hosting the Olympics,
and bidding on the Olympics is attractive,
but it absolutely comes with enormous
long term risks and costs.
After years of controversy and criticism,
mega sporting events
could be on the cusp of a
new, more sustainable era.
When it comes to organizing the games,
there must be a debate.
And we've done a lot of
reforms over the last decades,
to make sure that the
games remain relevant.
But will the changes be enough
to convince potential hosts?
One city's example might
offer a way forward.
We have the ability
to really fit the games to our community,
as opposed to have to fit
the community to the games.
The first winter World Cup,
held in the compact
affluent state of Qatar,
has drawn a massive number
of people to the country.
Organizers are expecting
some 1.2 million people
will come to the country
over the course of this month long event.
So you're essentially thinking
roughly a 10% increase
in population every night
in the most busy parts of the tournament.
Qatar's also really interested
in developing a tourism economy.
They've seen the success of Dubai.
And even though this is a much
more conservative country,
they think that they can draw people here
for other major sporting
events, for conferences,
just to visit on
stopovers to other places.
So they're hoping that
some of the new hotels,
and new entertainment venues and the like,
that they've built for the World Cup,
can get used by the next
generation of tourists.
Authorities estimate that
hosting the World Cup
could add as much as $17
billion into its economy.
But in order to get to that point,
the country has spent a
massive amount of money
over the past decade on infrastructure,
including building an entirely new city.
There are various estimates
of how much exactly Qatar
has spent in order to
prepare for this event.
The stadiums are really
just a small fraction.
While costs for the 2022 World Cup
are reportedly the highest ever
for a sporting competition,
it's part of an unsettling trend
for what are known as mega-events.
Mega means big.
Other than the day to day leagues,
the NBA, the NFL, MLB, NHL,
or the English Premier League,
the day to day leagues,
where they have every couple of days,
or if it's baseball, every
single day they have a new game,
that's standard economic issues.
But if it's something
where a lot of people
are coming from out of town,
and there's one big event or
there's one series of events,
like the Olympics is 17 days,
or the World Cup has
traditionally been around 28 days,
you're doing something special
that doesn't normally happen,
and involves tens of thousands,
if not millions of people,
then we call that a mega-event.
The first international
modern Olympics in 1896, held in Athens,
was considered the first
sporting mega-event,
the largest competition
ever held up to that time.
Although initially limited
to male amateur competitors
from only 14 countries,
the Olympics have expanded
significantly in size,
scope, and inclusivity since.
One key tradition that has
persisted for the past century,
is that the games travel every four years.
Every two years,
we have the Olympic Games
and the Winter Olympic Games,
which represent what the
movement collectively does,
and bring the best of the
sporting world together.
At the helm of the modern games
is an organization called
the International Olympic Committee,
made up of delegates from
participating nations.
The IOC is responsible
for choosing host cities,
and ensuring that the games are run
in accordance with IOC rules.
The movement has evolved tremendously
over more than a century.
It has gone through many developments,
as sport in the end reflects society,
and to remain relevant, this
is a constant adaptation.
For the first half century or so,
the games were a relatively
low budget affair.
But beginning in the 1960s,
the IOC and local planning
committees began to see value
in lucrative sponsorships
and global television rights.
As the potential rewards grew,
so did the scale of the events,
along with the cost to build
the infrastructure to host them.
Those costs however, are
not fronted by the IOC.
It's up to the host cities,
who bid for a chance to
reap the potential rewards.
But is it worth it?
Somewhere between four and $6
billion of revenue will get
generated by hosting the
Summer Games in these days.
On the expense side, it's
much, much, much higher.
That's not a good financial balance.
Projected costs
for an event on an Olympic
scale are expectedly high.
But the real trouble
cities can find themselves
facing is when projected costs
go substantially over budget,
often forcing governments
to absorb the overruns.
The University of Oxford in England
has done a number of studies
on costs and cost overruns.
And what they have found
is that since 1976,
the average cost overrun
or the medium cost overrun
for the Summer Games is 252%.
So that means 3.52 times the initial bid.
The whole point about these
studies is to constantly
be aware that organizing an
event like this is not a given.
It's a constant strive to make sure that,
that the games when it comes
to its economics do balance.
What drives costs
so exceedingly over
budget for mega-events?
Well, it's partly due to optimism bias,
in which planners simply assume
things will cost less
than they ultimately do.
Promoters might even intentionally
distort initial projections
to help win over stakeholders.
And by the time the
mega-event rolls around,
there's simply no other
option but to spend more.
If the Olympic Games are gonna start
on July 20th of a particular year,
you can't call up and say,
"Oh gee, we need another two weeks.
The Olympic Stadium won't
be ready on July 20th."
No, that can't happen.
And so once you have
that kind of a very firm
hard deadline in place, now
the construction companies
know that this has to be top priority.
And they have to start shifting workers
from other construction projects,
and shifting materials over there.
And that gives them an excuse
to bid up the prices still more.
So you have all of these
factors working together.
And all of a sudden you're
two, or three, or four,
or five times higher than the initial bid.
Not surprisingly,
enthusiasm for hosting the
games has varied over the years.
For a period, the game seemed cursed.
From tragic violence around
the 1968 in Mexico City
and 1972 Munich Summer Games,
to a debt-ridden financial
disaster in 1976,
that Montreal spent the
next 30 years paying off.
More recently, enormous budget overruns,
political controversies,
and viral scenes of decaying stadiums
in Athens, Rio de Janeiro, and Beijing,
have led some citizen activists
to openly question the
environmental impacts,
political optics, and cost
benefit ratio of hosting.
Boston is an absolutely beautiful city.
It looks great in the summertime.
It looks great when you envision
that helicopter or drone shot
looking over a brand new stadium
with fireworks going off,
and our gleaming skyline
in the background,
and the Charles River on one hand,
and Boston Harbor on the other.
It's really an impressive
and gorgeous place.
It's also on,
or in the most valuable
time zone in the world.
The East Coast time zone has something
like 40 or 50% of all of
American television viewers.
Boston beats out
Los Angeles, San Francisco, and DC,
and will be the US bid
in a worldwide battle for the 2024 games.
The polling was very clear that at first,
residents of Greater Boston
supported the Boston 2024 Olympic bid.
The idea of the Olympics
improving the public transportation
system in Massachusetts
was always the most
appealing and enticing part.
But what became clear is that over time,
the more people learned about
the implications of the bid,
the risks, and the costs,
that they got beyond those glossy images,
and saw what it would really mean
for their lives and for
the future of the state,
that people's support for the
games dropped dramatically.
We see that the bid requires
building the three most
expensive Olympic venues,
that every Olympics since
1960 has gone over budget.
We felt that there needed
to be a real debate about
whether the Olympics
was the right thing for
Massachusetts or not.
And we saw that because
of the power of the people
pushing the bid, there were
gonna be very few institutions,
that would normally ask
tough questions of the bid,
that were gonna do that in this case.
And so that opposition had
to come from the grassroots,
and that's why we formed
No Boston Olympics.
Boston 2024's original proposal
was to put beach volleyball
here in Boston Common,
not a place that has sand,
not a place along the water.
And one of the most
historic public spaces,
and important public spaces in the US.
This is the original public
park in North America.
Boston was the first major city
to stand up and say no
to the summer 2024 games.
But in the wake of our decision in Boston,
other cities dropped out.
Rome, Italy had been
talking about bidding.
A new mayor was elected there who said
she had more important
priorities than the Olympics,
and so that bid died.
Hamburg, Germany, actually
had a public referendum
to bid on the 2024 games,
and voted that down in November of 2015.
Budapest Hungary, there was a grassroots
opposition to the games there,
that forced the question of the Olympics
to be on the ballot.
And eventually the
organizers of the games there
decided not to move forward with it.
In 2017, left with a dwindling
set of potential hosts for the 2024 games.
The International Olympic Committee
made an unprecedented move.
It awarded the two remaining
contenders at the same time.
Paris for 2024 and Los Angeles for 2028,
giving the IOC some extra breathing room
and a chance to focus
on a series of reforms
You have to listen to critics as well.
And we've been in contact with them,
and other opponents to the games.
Because this is our mission,
to listen and to make
sure that their analysis,
we do understand why they
reached these conclusions,
and what we can improve.
In the late 1970s,
the IOC was in a similarly
desperate position
facing backlash after
a series of blemished
events earlier in the decade.
Sensing a rare opportunity for leverage,
the city of Los Angeles
decided that it could make
the 1984 Olympics a
success, but on its terms.
What happened in '84 was
good for Los Angeles,
it turned out for some
very interesting reasons.
But it was a disaster,
'cause the IOC had to give up
on many of its requirements.
The IOC requires for instance,
that a host city guarantee,
that it will carry out all
of the tasks in its contract,
and take full responsibility financially
for any costs that are involved.
In 1984, because Los Angeles
was the only city that was bidding,
the IOC basically was on its knees
in front of the Los Angeles committee
saying, "Please, please do this."
And so the Los Angeles
Committee dictated terms,
and one of the terms was,
we're not gonna be
responsible for cost overruns.
By most accounts,
the 1984 Los Angeles Summer
Games were a resounding success.
Instead of saddling taxpayers
with a catastrophic loss,
the games were actually profitable,
thanks to the strategic
corporate sponsorships
and manageable costs.
Because the metropolitan area already
had suitable stadiums,
venues, and housing,
very little new construction was needed,
preventing the sort of surprise expenses
that had played earlier host cities.
And now, amid another challenging
period for the Olympics,
Los Angeles is again trying
to rewrite the narrative.
We like to say that the
LA '84 games are actually
what gives us the ability
to have such great
public support here in
Los Angeles for the games.
You can't walk around this city
and not meet somebody who has
a positive memory of 1984.
And that's really the
starting place for us.
We are a no build games.
And sometimes we like to say
it's a part of our radical
reuse philosophy around sustainability.
The fact is the best venues
are the ones you don't have to build.
Right over my shoulder, you can see
one of the main pieces that
will actually be the secret
sauce of LA being able to
host the Olympic games,
and that's UCLA.
We have UCLA and USC within really a,
just about 10 or 12 miles of each other.
And really that's the beginning
stages of infrastructure.
But beyond that, you know,
we really have just an
extraordinary number of venues
here in LA and in greater
Southern California,
whether it's three
facilities, three stadiums,
that are over 75,000 seats,
multiple arenas, different
types of facilities.
And so we're just tailor made to be able
to actually host a mega sporting event,
like the Olympics and the Paralympics.
As for potential cost overruns,
LA '28 has a plan in mind.
We actually are carrying a 10% contingency
from day one in our budget,
in terms of how and what it is
that we actually think about.
And so we're trying to build
against that contingency.
I think it's incumbent upon all of us
to think about everything that we do,
and think about it through
the lens of sustainability.
We'll have probably just shy
of a hundred thousand jobs,
that will be a part of our
journey over the next six years.
And that's billions of
dollars of economic impact
directly to citizens of LA.
Beyond the raw cost benefit figures,
there is another value
to the Olympics that is harder to measure.
For us, it's really about human legacy.
And it starts actually
with the kids that we want to be sitting
in the stadiums thinking and dreaming,
that they too can be an
Olympian or a Paralympian.
It was a part of our Play LA program,
which is our $160 million
investment into kids in Los Angeles.
One of the real important parts
of that is we've introduced
adaptive sports into the
recs and park program
in the city of LA.
I'm optimistic about the '28
games for the same reasons.
I think that they have really excellent
management of the organizing committee,
and they're Los Angeles.
They've got a lot more stadiums
now than they had back in 1984,
and they've got more infrastructure,
including public transportation
that they didn't have.
So I think it'll turn
out, it'll turn out well.
Meanwhile, at the other
end of the spectrum,
there are places where costs
simply aren't a major concern.
But this path comes with
its own set of problems.
The person who really seems
to have wanted to host
the World Cup more than anyone else
is Sheik Hamad bin Khalifa Al Thani.
He's now known as the Father Emir.
He was the former ruler of Qatar.
And this was really his desire,
not just to host, you know, a
massive football tournament.
He knew that it would drive
an enormous amount of
development in the country,
that Qatar really needed to
become a kind of modern place.
And that's exactly what happened.
In the last decade alone,
Qatar has built more roads,
bicycle paths, and bridges,
than during the entire
previous half century.
Funded by a robust petroleum
and natural gas based economy,
the government was less
concerned with short term profit,
and more interested in the long term
benefits of future tourism,
business development, and global prestige.
For instance, they've
gone to great lengths
and no doubt expense,
to show off cutting
edge engineering feats,
such as this innovative stadium design
constructed partly out
of shipping containers,
meant to be easily deconstructed
and transported elsewhere.
But the attention the nation has received
has generally not been so positive.
Behind the scenes, many
more are being exploited,
unpaid, forced labor, badly treated.
It's very hard to give an exact figure.
I would suspect it's
actually in the hundreds.
I think hundreds of workers
have died to make this World Cup possible.
There was initially reports
about the deaths of workers
in stadium projects and other projects
directly tied to the World Cup.
This obviously set off an
enormous international outcry,
and ultimately the government did start
making reforms in order
to respond to this.
So people were living in very cramped,
unsafe, unsanitary accommodations.
They've set minimum standards on that.
They also introduced a
universal minimum wage,
meaning it applies to
people of all nationalities.
It's not much, it's about $274 a month.
But it's something,
and in fact, it's the first
universal minimum wage
across the gulf region generally.
Activists are not entirely happy
with the reforms that
Qatari government has made.
They don't believe that
some of these reforms
have gone far enough.
On worker deaths, for instance,
nobody really had bothered
to count for a long time
how many workplace deaths and injuries
you had across the country.
Activists are very concerned about
what happens after everyone goes home.
I think these are questions
we don't know the answer to.
Qatar's hope is that in the long run,
memories of compelling matches
will outlast any lingering controversy.
The 2022 World Cup story
echoes other mega-events in recent years,
where strong centralized governments
have spent lavishly to
help build global prestige,
only to find themselves
marred by controversy.
If you look for example
at the 2022 Winter
Olympic bidding process,
all of the democracies that
were bidding in that process
actually dropped out before
the final bidding phase.
The only two cities that were left
were Beijing, China
and Almaty, Kazakhstan,
both autocratic countries,
where there's no democracy,
there's no input,
there's no opportunity
for residents to push back
against the extravagance of the games.
Russia received a 4-year ban
for doping from the
world Anti-Doping Agency.
China has been criticized
by some countries and human rights groups
over what they say is abuse
against Uyghur Muslims.
They're gonna be under increasing
pressures from corporate sponsors.
They're creating all sorts of problems,
in terms of how the
labor force is treated,
in terms of environmental
destruction, and so on.
So corporations are sort of pulling back.
Or they're saying, "Well, if
you expect us to stay around,
you've gotta clean this stuff up."
Mounting public concerns
from citizens, cities, and sponsors,
over the recent state
of controversial games
have forced organizing bodies,
like FIFA and the IOC, to pursue reforms.
One approach to address
the sustainability concern
has been to spread out mega-events
over a region or even a continent,
instead of forcing a single
city to take on the burden.
I think FIFA has an easier job,
only because there are more places
that have the necessary
venues and infrastructure.
And because of the very
profound, and lasting,
and pervasive popularity of soccer,
they have more leeway,
I think, than the IOC.
So hopefully, we'll see
some good changes there.
Ends of vote...
In fact, things
are already
looking differently.
Starts now.
In the next World Cup,
which will be spread out in 16
cities across North America,
and rely mostly on
existing infrastructure.
The World Cup is coming
back to Boston in 2026.
And it never crossed our minds
to create a No Boston World Cup group,
because the costs are just
gonna be a small fraction
of what hosting the
Olympics would've been.
As for the Olympics,
the IOC has spent the past decade
reflecting on its complex legacy,
and outlining broad new reforms
aimed at reinventing the games
for the sustainability
conscious 21st century.
Listen, the most important
was a decade ago,
when we adopted a motto that,
"A city does not adapt to the games,
but the games adapt to a city."
Then the second thing
which was important is,
we don't build if it's
not absolutely needed.
We have a sustainability agenda,
that is very appealing as well.
It'll be climate positive
as a rule from 2030,
but already Paris 2024
will be climate positive,
which is a great objective to reach.
I think everybody also is recognizing
the efforts when it
comes to sustainability,
and the whole agenda, economic,
social, and environmental.
Yes, it's more to deliver
for the organizers,
but for the better.
A successful Olympics is one
that, first and foremost,
brings back to the community
what they were expecting.
Even the bidding process,
once a fierce competition that often
encourage the sort of wild promises,
that led to financial
pitfalls, has been reshaped.
It is a partnership now.
So we have cities that come to us and say,
"Listen, what does it take
if I want to organize the games in 2040?"
And the big difference is that
the IOC is not judging anymore
the quality of a given value proposition.
It is contributing to it.
The plans for upcoming games,
Los Angeles in 2028, Milan in
2030, and Brisbane in 2032,
already seem to be heeding
the warning signs of the past,
so far at least.
But some critics have proposed
an even more radical concept.
What I would favor in the long run,
what I think is most rational,
particularly in these
days of climate change,
and the need to conserve resources
and not waste resources,
is we ought to have one city,
that hosts the games permanently.
Having everyone agree
on a single host city
might be a challenging diplomatic problem.
Regardless, the institutional reforms
within the World Cup and the Olympics
demonstrate that mega sporting events
can respond to the demands
of an ever-evolving planet,
and the days of massive cost overruns
and wasteful infrastructure
may be behind us.
I think there are much more
sensible ways to proceed.
Whether the world decides
to be sensible or not,
I think it's still an undecided question.